[Music]
that is like my personal dream is I want
to get Nick Cage on here but to have him
say nothing
I wanted to just chill and then we just
podcast like normal and then at the very
end he just maybe goes huh
that's it yeah we've been hoping for
that for so long literally we just get a
five second shot of him just sitting
there and then we constantly cut back to
it he never doesn't say anything the
whole episode we've tried even pitching
to his people like he just has to drop
by for like five minutes he doesn't even
have to be here and we can't we can't
that's our white our white whale
can you make it happen
you don't see what he's doing yeah [ __ ]
he just got me
anyways what'd you do this weekend uh
what did I do
um because this is late this comes out
later so you got to predict the future
because we definitely did not record
this before no this comes out tomorrow
oh this one the episode we did yesterday
comes out next week
this comes out next week the episode
you're right yeah so actually this
weekend I um [ __ ] predicted okay I'll
I'll tell you what I did Mr Beast called
me up he said
do you want a quarter of a million
dollars wow yeah what's your account
number I'm wiring it to you right now
and I said are you sure you should give
that to someone you said no I want to
give it to you yeah
so I gave him the number sure enough a
similar thing I announced my tour and he
goes hey bro I bought out all the
tickets and I'm just gonna give them
away to your people I was like and he's
just gonna be the only one at every show
oh that would be miserable
I have to call him and tell him don't do
that
yeah
I mean it's really nice of him though
yeah extremely look at the paycheck yeah
do you want to comment on this or you're
good
there's your practice
but how much would it cost to buy every
ticket in your tour because that would
be kind of funny
or just one one stop one stop how much
how much is it
um it really depends the the capacities
are different okay you could do like do
a show in North Carolina I am oh really
yeah when
let me see it would be so funny here if
we walk hey could you just can you leave
the room for just like one minute please
I need to just tell him something no
please no is there some like noise
canceling headphones we can put on them
no no they don't like this I don't like
this at all I already know what I'm
gonna do and I'm gonna do it if he does
one near me but I don't want him to hear
it because it'll ruined it
damn it I want I want to know uh all
right hey Reid I need confirmation he's
not within hearing no no you can still
hear over there okay make sure you can't
hear me all right imagine if when he
does someone in North Carolina I have
like you know I have a couple hundred
employees I have all the employees buy a
ticket using their company car but then
none of them go except for me and it's
just so he thinks it's a sold out show
with hundreds of people but it's just me
and I just sit dead center and then he
comes out and it's only me with a bucket
of popcorn and would would you film it
or would you just do that no just do it
for fun haha
bro tell me that wouldn't be funny I
mean it'd be hysterical popcorn at a
comedy show yeah it was so funny hey I'm
on a podcast can I call you later
um did I hear it I knew that something
you would do [ __ ] God well then I'm not
gonna do it now because you know it's
only funny if you don't expect it here's
what would be really funny is if you
bought out all the tickets but everyone
got like a call sheet beforehand and
they're like okay so when Noel gets on
stage get up and walk out or or just
stay completely silent a boo or some
[ __ ] yeah no just completely silent to
everything you say okay I got ideas just
get one near Greenville North Carolina
we'll make something happen I don't
think I'm anywhere near Greenville you
should be it's middle of nowhere yeah
but hey if you are I'm doing two stops
in North Korea if you do shoot me a text
okay I got you what what major city is
close to Greenville Greenville
no like I mean no like the major ones in
like but even I don't know with the Room
Raleigh but Raleigh's so far away like
that one Charlotte I don't care how much
Charlotte's even further away oh then
I'm good yeah all right I guess no joke
I'm doing Charlotte and maybe do one in
Raleigh and if it's you know so if it's
a slow day we might hook something up
yeah I did Raleigh earlier this year so
yeah it did sell out yeah okay see get
you another one there we'll see what
happens
no I'm never gonna tell you that'd be my
fault hey I don't give a whole [ __ ] hey
I'll tell you you guys your Giga chat
you pay it's ten dollars a month you
just tell me I'm not gonna lie when I
said if you buy a ticket before I buy
them [ __ ] you
I want them all every single one of them
when you they double the price I will
yeah but no actually they're gonna buy
them quick oh yeah my body is gonna be
like the next day true yeah yeah if one
of you buy every ticket the second he
drops it I'll pay double if you just
give them all to me but you gotta buy
all of them [ __ ] Live Nation is just
yo
rolly popping you were trying to sorry
we're just trying to figure this out man
the whole theater got bought out by one
guy
and then now those went to Ticketmaster
another rebought on SeatGeek I think
people do that they definitely do that
yeah yeah can you just buy out your own
show
would you say can you buy out your own
show yeah didn't wait didn't somebody do
that 50 Cent did that to Ja Rule yes he
bought out the front rows yeah all of
his concerts yeah there's no one there
yeah good [ __ ] so far we all need a boy
like that yeah yeah just no no bro you
licking your lips there what was that oh
it's that nervous yeah but you went for
like four rounds oh sorry
[Laughter]
man I'm hard as [ __ ] right now no the 50
Cent Ja Rule thing was a dick move he
they did it because they were like yeah
50 was trying to embarrass him so
there'd be no one in the front row while
he was performing this music oh [ __ ] so
it didn't look yeah oh my God yo if I
want to troll someone I could buy like
half the seats but like you know sputter
them around yes exactly like but we
should do that at Schultz
[Music]
90 of the tickets have my employees
doing on their company cards different
names and everything but none of them
show up so that he just thinks he's
[ __ ] that would be a really good
prank but it's a mean prank for sure I'd
sit front row I take one of the tickets
they're like hey man do that one I like
yeah he'd be like the [ __ ] are you doing
here
could you imagine buying out you know
what Schultz would be pretty funny I
might do that to him instead because he
wouldn't see it coming no and then I
just get a Heckle with him the whole
time yeah but I would like demand to do
the show Do It clown I own you I need
this in my life yeah
he just did a video with Casey today
where they went surfing it was awesome
yet have you been watching Casey's
videos since he's been back in New York
no yeah I watched a few did you watch
his videos like back when he was daily
oh 100 right it's like it gives me that
same feeling I feel like I went back a
couple years I know it's weird yeah it's
awesome life feels simpler when I watch
Casey neistat yeah but now that I'm
friends with him in person like I know
his
his like mannerisms in the way that he
speaks what you know him in person just
had to slide that one in you know now
I'm best
you are also friends of them are you not
yeah but I didn't have to tell everyone
you just said you were flying to South
Africa yeah but I didn't go yeah Casey
you know now that we're friends
I'm just saying I surf I just
no I'm just saying his I'm just saying
his his mannerisms remind me
oh man I'm dead
I was if you would let me finish I was
gonna say his mannerisms remind me a lot
of post Malone who we're also friends
with
oh boy so Cody do you slap it on the
tongue before you took it
[Music]
holy [ __ ] Bro can we make this the real
one and the other one the paper no no
[Music]
hell no oh my God
[Laughter]
you know it's just I'm I'm glad Jimmy's
here because you know now you can Ultra
name drop and I just get to watch it's
funny that everyone you named is going
to Antarctica with me
like Casey imposters are they actually
yeah wait so you're actually so you're
doing it yeah well can we go
sure but do you also want to visit
Antarctica yeah okay what do you mean
that I don't know what do you mean just
so you can't you can't just like hitch a
ride no no oh it's difficult whoever
clipped that and tweet at him and then
he'll get the joke it takes a little
while sometimes what me yeah oh you're
saying because you said could I come and
I was like sure no and then [ __ ]